you're operating profits were up 10%
last year of all we all key European
markets come back from the terrorist
incidence of 16 and 17 but he did I
guess UK is being still going strong
transmuting rebounding very nicely
Portugal Spain very strong Germany still
there so it's pretty rosy Amsterdam very
strong is your Pacific very strong the
only two places in which we had
weaknesses GCC the Gulf and Brazil what
was that do you think in different
geopolitical issues and Brazil funny
enough Brazil is very strong in San
Paulo and weak in Rio but is there
getting back on their feet pretty strong
I guess you have the Olympics in 2016 so
there's a year-on-year comparator every
year we have something good coming to us
it's a blessed industry you just had
which is why Airbnb booking with the
answers is attacking because it's
sizeable profitable growing industry
demand outpacing supply by twice so no
question it interests everybody
including myself now the year euro has
been on an absolute tear over the last
year particularly against the US dollar
which is significant because a lot of
consumers from emerging markets
reference the dollar has that impacted
on travel from the likes of China and
India no you know at the end of the day
for us we have a local hedging so
everything we do is local economy
currency based and every cost is also
local economy currency based so I guess
we don't we benefit like the pounds
brexit uncertainty we've never had so
much growth in UK because international
travelers want to benefit from the lower
pounds UK guys stay and stakeholders
basically stay in the UK because they
can't afford going elsewhere so it's
it's of interesting things Forex doesn't
really have any impact on our Co Hotel
growth and profitability thank you are
you one of the big hotel off races to
first start thinking about how you take
on the likes of Airbnb do you think
you're winning that battle you've got to
learn to live with them I guess well I
guess first I have a lot of admiration
for anybody around me so they are
getting stronger bigger and more
profitable more visible but I guess I
was extremely worried couple years ago
they're being actually flattening out in
terms of gross regulation happens so
they don't really know where they sit
and so and I'm just accustomed to it and
if anything I have to be minded is what
do they do for the guy that they love so
much because they are growing
and the guess what they lost so much
about it is cheaper it is space here and
it's more fun so I just need to make my
hotels a bit cheaper a bit more special
and more fun and you wonder we can't do
it
the trouble is you've got to be really
on your game at all times in an age of
online rating apps I mean if people
don't like your product and/or service
they'll put it out on the internet right
there which is good you had to be client
minded no longer product minded you have
to get your eyes wide open you need to
get all the financial resources with you
you need to be agile you bit to be on
the move you need to watch your cur
system and we're going to need to
partner with some of them and it's a
fascinating world but AK who is the
leader any place on the planet but China
in America so if they were to partner
with somebody I maybe the founders of
choice now you're a well-connected man
Nicolas Sarkozy's on your board I know
you know president macron very well is
he the real deal I mean there's
expectations really high for what he's
gonna do going to achieve for France is
he gonna live up to them answers yes yes
yes he is he's a remarkable person he
has a mandate he didn't hide anything
before I got elected people know what he
wants to accomplish
he's extremely strong minded he's
audacious he's lucky he has great vision
he is charming
so which means and he's been you should
have probably seen it what he said today
on a podium he said you know guys I'm
not here to be liked I'm not here to
please anybody I'm here to act so he has
a plan he has a team he has a calendar
and he wants to leave something behind
rot age right person multi-culture yeah
I think he's gonna do it he's gonna
surprise everybody and hopefully he's
gonna stay for a long time briefly
Sebastian what about the UK you still
committed to the UK post brexit well I
like being hearing any private companies
thing am I going to stay am I going to
exit let me tell you something for as
far as travel leisure industry our core
is not only staying here but our core is
going to be growing in UK creating job
opening your hotel this is a fabulous
country you have absolutely everything
it's a great place to visit great place
to enjoy food and many other things so
now our Co is growing coming to the UK
and you know what we never left any
country in the times of turmoil so if
you want to be back in countries be
there when they need you the most so we
here